what do you love most about being on a
movie set
i mean i love being able to
have conversations with people that like
are all working towards the same goal
and like you know i've i've kind of
started to figure out my my my method of
directing has kind of changed over the
years
i used to always think that i had the
best ideas and i had to like you know
everybody had to listen to exactly what
i think and then i started to go oh my
god i have all these really smart people
around me
that are like brilliant and have you
know invested their time in this in this
vision as well
what i really should do is shape other
people's ideas you know what i mean so
like what i started to do is like you
know it's it's it's like much more
collaborative so like you know i have
conversations in more broad strokes with
people than see what they bring back to
me and then i start shaping it from
there and so i think it's it's much more
collaborative in that sense because i
feel like you know a good director
doesn't have to have the best ideas they
just have to recognize good ones and so
what i've started to do is i i start to
direct people to to shape it towards
something that's more like what i
envisioned but while still
bringing in what they brought to the
table because people come in and they go
i got this bag of tools i could do this
i could do this you know and actors
whatever uh and you can can you can do
that i mean you know when i was working
with mel on this last movie mel
uh
saw the character much funnier than it
was written and and and i really loved
that idea and then him and i kind of
started shaping that character together
and i think you know a lot of that uh
you know when people bring ideas to the
table that work for the overall story uh
or or the overall look of the film it's
it's it's really great to be able to
collaborate with them so i think my
favorite thing about uh a film set is
just having collaboration with the
people that i'm working with
what is day one like on a film set for
you
it's probably the most hectic day of the
entire thing
i always say it's like first day of
school blues it's like you know
everybody's there and they're still kind
of just figuring out what their place is
on set um you know and and and you know
you've had all this prep but like you
know how do you how do you how do you
work with these people in a pressure
cooker because like you know once you're
on set it's more pressure you know it's
my in prep it's more like ah
it's this this but how do we work on set
when there's more pressure and so i
would say like you know for me i i kind
of like to take it in more on the first
day and kind of figure out like where
we're at and and figure out like the
different personalities and how they
mesh together and then uh and then kind
of work from there i you know it's it's
not it's not uh it's it's more of a
relaxed first day for me i mean we're
still trying to make our day for sure
but it's more of me just fully
understanding you know how people are so
i try to stay away from doing much
harder stuff
on the first day of a film shoot so that
i can kind of gauge what the actual
environment is
because i bet you're a really good
read of people you can you can probably
walk into a room and be like okay this
is this and this is this and i'm going
to be over here and i try to i try to
think like that i try to um but like you
know i
who knows who knows maybe i am maybe i'm
not i i try to i try to be a good read
of people but you know it's uh it's the
one thing about making movies is you're
dealing with a lot of personalities and
so like you know trying to figure out
how to manage and get along with all
personalities i think is one of the the
jobs of the director because you know a
lot of directors can be angry and this
and that but you get more flies with
honey than you do with with with vinegar
i mean uh i
i
i try to you know make it fun and
and you know joke around and be playful
with with the uh people i work with
except sometimes i try to annoy my dp
because i think it's funny uh but beyond
that
i i try to get along with everybody i i
mind you i i love my dp but he uh the
most of the dps i've worked with are
very like stoic people
like they're very like very very quiet
stoic people so i've always just been
like oh
can i annoy them
[Laughter]
i see is it a challenge it's somewhat of
a challenge but i don't like i'm just
being playful it's nice
they know i'm joking with them it's not
like i'm being mean or anything but but
it's just like you know
can i
what about the last day what's that like
for you on set
the last day is usually a rush to you
know get
everything that you've kind of been
trying to pick up and do stuff so it's
like one of those like like non-stop
like ah and then it's like an adrenaline
dump of like oh it's over like you know
and you get the you get like that oh man
you wrapped and then you know you you
have all the actors that are like you
know saying goodbye they're like hey we
think we made something great like
they're like you know you know they're
they're looking to you to be reassuring
that like hey job well done we did it
um so it's it's you know it's it's
i i would imagine it's you know the same
as like you know
a teacher would feel when people are all
graduating at the end of the you know at
the end of the semester or whatever it's
like you know bye guys good work
good luck with everything keep in touch
i mean i guess i don't know
i'd imagine it's like that
what goes through your mind when you
wrap a film in your driving home
sadly it's it's it's probably like thank
god i can finally sleep
um to be honest
i think it starts to like really come
together like a week after
if that makes sense and i start to go
like wow this is really cool yeah we did
this it's like that but i mean like a
lot of the time it's just like oh man
finally sleep
okay so so maybe then i should say
let's say a week after and you don't
have anything booked which has probably
not been the case for a long time with
you seem like you're very busy but let's
just suppose you have a little bit of
downtime so once the the fog clears and
you're actually on a normal sleeping
pattern
what what goes through your mind about
the film i mean that's that's hard too
because i'm super involved in post so
it's more so just like i'm like okay i
can't wait to see this edit and i start
asking the editor who's already looking
at the footage hey what did you did you
see this what are you thinking have you
read the script let's start talking i
already started talking to the composer
like i don't stop if that makes sense so
i stay in that world and i try to get
all my thoughts going before i lose the
vibe of what i had from when i was on
set
um
so i i don't know
i i don't
it's hard like i wish i had like a a
better
thing i mean
but it's it's more just like okay we got
to keep pushing this thing to the finish
line a lot of people have the like their
job ends you know when the movie wraps
but i spend
the next five six seven eight months you
know
maybe sometimes to a year working on
this thing non-stop so
i like that so so keeping in the same
headspace the same vibe
that you were on set and then taking
that out there into the edit room yeah
trying to there's the movie that we make
before we start filming it there's the
movie that we make when we're filming it
and there's the movie that we make after
we're done filming it you know and so
like before i have all these plans and
ideas and this then there's the
execution where you're like okay maybe
75 percent of that i was able to do and
then there's the there's the
there's the
post-production phase where you're like
okay well this is what i meant to do and
you got to remember like okay maybe
there was the shot that you shot that
was like gonna count as a twofer because
you swing down and swing back up and you
can like but that's something that like
maybe it's written down by the scripty
maybe it isn't maybe you were moving too
fast to say it so you're trying to
remember exactly how you shot this
footage and you're like okay the the way
i shoot footage a lot of the time also
is like i i like a lot of coverage and
certain things i do like that have to
cut to another thing so i'm like okay i
want my editor to really know what i was
thinking um and how i was shooting it
luckily the editor of my newest movies
edited two of my movies back to back and
now this is the third movie so he
already probably looks at this footage
and goes oh i know exactly what he was
thinking because he's dealt with me
twice
what about the fourth which would be the
audience's reaction
the audience's reaction i you know i
always hope that the audience is gonna
like the movie um you know and and i i
you know i definitely
get excited about promoting the movie to
the audience and and excited about
talking about it and and doing you know
the interviews to talk about the film
and and you know i'm always very
grateful when people like the movie and
they reach out uh and you know the whole
thing is is is moving towards the
audience um and that's probably the
scariest part of filmmaking uh you know
because it's you put a year of your life
into something and somebody could just
you know look at it and just be like
yeah it's boring and it's this you know
you put a year of your life into
something and you know it's it's people
just don't like it for whatever reason
you know maybe they had a bad day maybe
they had this maybe they had that so for
me
that's probably the scariest part so
i probably try not to think about that
but you strike me as the kind of person
that even though you don't want to just
make somebody mad that you're going to
do what you're going to do regardless i
try to make what i believe is going to
be the best movie possible
um and
my movies aren't always for everyone
but i hope that the people that they are
for will enjoy them
do you actively read reviews
i read all of them yeah i read all of
them a lot of people say that they
shouldn't that you shouldn't but i read
all of them because my dad used to read
me my bad reviews he would call me and
read me my bad reviews on my movies um
and we would laugh and he would say no
no don't laugh
you know if you saw like he would say if
you see like five reviews saying the
same thing
you know maybe that's something you can
fix for the next one you know if you
have like so
you know there's some stuff that's one
way or another way but i'm like okay
well if if like all of these people say
like the second act is super slow
maybe i should have paced that up so
maybe i can in the future kind of be
cognizant of that and keep that in the
back of my mind so that we have like a
little bit more stuff to break that up i
mean i'm still learning and growing i'm
you know i'm not i'm i'm 29 i'm
you know i'm still young so i'm i'm
still finding my style and voice as a
filmmaker and i think a lot of that is
is learning and growing and and testing
stuff and and seeing what works and what
doesn't and
um you know and and i'm trying to
develop as a filmmaker and learn from
everything that i do so i think you know
it's it's important to look at the
you know
the negative reviews even though
sometimes they sting and also you know i
maybe to desensitize me from people
being like ah that sucked you know
why so when he would do that in the
beginning would you say stop or did you
welcome it because you realized there
was he was trying to help you in some
way
i mean my dad had a way of saying things
that no matter how he said it they were
always funny
um so
and i would always tell him to stop
whatever he was doing because uh it was
you know
incredibly annoying but also funny
um so
probably told him to stop probably
didn't listen you know
[Laughter]
my dad was uh my dad was just a big he
was a character he was like a living
cartoon character
wow that's interesting though i mean
that's a good lesson on on being not not
just learning that okay the second act
was this or that but also being
desensitized because there's so many
reasons that someone's going to say what
they're going to say yeah
there's not just
you know they're trying to
help you there's different agendas for
sure for sure
so i mean that's you know and the thing
that uh my dad always said about this
business is like you know you got to
have thick skin
and i think it's more
true more now than ever because you know
anybody can make a comment about
anything now
um you know it's it's you you
a
trailer goes up for one of your movies
there's a thousand comments on it you
know within hours nowadays uh and like
you know so it's it's it's
you gotta you gotta get thick skin um
and you gotta hope that the people that
do like your stuff like your stuff you
know and the people that don't you know
hopefully they'll like the next one
is it hard to let the good comments in
if you have thick skin if you've been
like okay all right yeah they didn't
like it yeah we got this i totally love
the good comments people that like my
movies i'm
for me i mean like i'm i'm like i would
say like maybe like
it depends like you know i've said a few
times don't watch my early movies right
i've had people say hey i love your
earlier movies i'm like jesus they must
not like good
like
like oh man why do you like that movie
um
but you know i
i i definitely appreciate the the good
comments i mean i think a lot of people
forget when they're commenting on things
and saying things that like you know 100
people 200 people worked on this thing
you know and like you know
the person who made it spent a year a
year and a half working on it uh poured
their you know they did the best they
could they poured their heart into it uh
i think people forget that sometimes
um
and so i i you know it's it's it's
it's very
it means a lot to me when people say
they like the stuff that i do um you
know it's part of what keeps me wanting
to do stuff is the the few people that
have really really reached out and said
that they really like it um you know i
think that's kind of uh it's it's
it i you know it's artists we're all
sensitive people you know it's uh so
being able to be told that you know
something connected with somebody and it
resonates with them is is special
it makes it all feel worth it